"f" es una función lineal que toma valores conforme a la siguiente tabla,
aquí nos dan algunos valores de "x"
y los valores que toman "f" en esos puntos.
¿Cuáles gráficas corresponden a funciones que crecen más rápido que "f"?
Y aquí nos dan estas cuatro gráficas.
Ahora bien que algo crezca,
que una función crezca más rápido que "f",
lo que quiere decir es que su tasa de cambio promedio es más grande .
En el caso de funciones lineales
como estas líneas rectas,
o es "f" que nos dicen que es función lineal.
Lo que significa es que la tasa de cambio
entre el eje vertical y el eje horizontal,
tiene que ser más grande que la de "f".
Así que vamos a encontrar, cuál es la tasa de cambio.
La tasa de cambio se define por
cuánto cambias...
cuánto cambia tu función,
dividido entre cuánto cambia tu variable.
Ok, para algún cambio de la variable ¿cuánto cambia la función?
Recuerden este triangulito es la letra griega nabla.
Así que bien, analicemos aquí si mi función...
déjenme lo anoto acá abajo
delta "f" entre delta "x"...
esto es igual a cuánto...
Si aquí cambio "x" por 1
aquí incrementé a "x" en 1,
entonces ese aumentó en 5.
Por lo tanto tengo mi cambio en "x" fue 1
y mi cambio en "f" fue de 5
Podría ser lo mismo acá,
aquí aumente "x" en uno
y aquí aumente "x"...
perdón "f" en 5.
Y como es lineal,
de hecho siempre va a ser la misma tasa de cambio,
incluso si fuera digamos desde el 1 hasta el 3,
en donde aumente "x" por dos unidades,
delta "x" es 2,
y delta "f" sería,
10,
porque estoy pasando en -9 a 1 positivo,
10 entre 2 de nuevo es 5,
así que
mi pendiente o mi tasa de cambio es 5.
Ahora, quiero encontrar que gráficas corresponden
a funciones que cambian más rápido que "f",
es decir que tienen una tasa de cambio promedio mayor a 5.
Ahora bien,
"a"
podemos notar que está decreciendo
"a" no está creciendo,
está disminuyendo,
por lo tanto "a"
ni siquiera la voy a a checar...
"a" no puede ser.
ahora "b",
si yo me paro aquí en "b",
me paro en este punto
que está sobre la gráfica
y me muevo una unidad sobre el eje "x",
entonces, tendría que alzarme cinco unidades
para tener una tasa de cambio igual a "f",
así que veamos cuánto me alzo.
En este punto ahora,
me alzo
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 unidades también.
Por lo tanto la tasa de cambio de "b",
es igual a la tasa de cambio de "f".
No es que esté creciendo más rápido,
simplemente que tiene la misma tasa de cambio,
así que "b" tampoco funciona.
¿Qué hay de "c"?
si en "c" yo me paro digamos aquí, que es un punto
que tiene coordenadas enteras -3, - 2
y avanzó una unidad...
avanzo una unidad en el eje "x"
¿cuántas unidades tengo que subir en el eje "y"?
Pues tengo que subir 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6....
6 y un poquito más.
Y entonces la tasa de cambio de esta función es,
6 más un cachito entre 1
que es mayor a 5 por lo tanto "c" si funciona.
Y ¿qué hay de "d"?
de nuevo, me paro en un punto con
coordenadas enteras, por ejemplo este,
me muevo una unidad a la derecha
y me fijo en cuanto me alzó 1 2
1, 2, 3...
3 y un poquito.
Entonces 3 y un poquito entre 1
sigue siendo menor a 5,
por lo tanto "d" crece más lentamente que "f".
La tasa de cambio de "d" es menor a la de "f"
y por lo tanto la única función,
que crece más rápido que "f",
es la función que está representada
por la gráfica "c".